okay so uh
once yossi gets uh set up he's gonna
talk about observing
uh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and quantum necromancy
it's a joint work with
my host in
[Music]
previous hosting ut hostings for
torrenson and with linux lasskman from
stanford
and um
now what we do here is we basically uh
use uh
computational complexity to tackle the
measurement problem in uh
in
quantum mechanics
and we we try to say when um a
macroscopic superposition effectively
collapse
and there's also some take on idea cft
so what is the measurement problem
so we start with
the two-slit experiment and we have a
source that emits
photons one by one
and the photon
interferes and hits the screen
here
and we got used to the fact that the
photon has some quantum behavior that it
exists in two places in the same time
here
and here it becomes a classical
information and we
we can replicate it we can observe it by
our own eyes
and quantum mechanics tells us what is
the distribution of the
position of the electro of the photon at
the end but it doesn't tell us exactly
how
the transition from quantum to
to classical
happens
and
this can be
become strange very quickly
um so for example we can put uh
detectors in the path
of the uh
of the photon
if the detector if the photon goes up
uh
then detector a clicks
if the photon goes down detector b
clicks
and from uh linearity of quantum
mechanics
if the photon in is in superposition of
up and down then
this the detectors becomes entangled
with the state of the photon with the
path of the photon
and so they don't have
a classical uh define definite state so
you cannot say even
which um
which of the detector clicked
and it gets even stranger if we think
about the experimentalist as another
subsystem here
and so now the state of the the
experimentalist becomes a dongle with
the path of the photo and then there is
no really end to this
um
so
the questions are
very fundamental aren't we governed by
the same laws of the particles we're
measuring
the fact that we're a microscopical
being
makes us somehow feel classical about
the world
and there is no
um
exactly exact boundary between a class a
classical and quantum behavior
and
when
if ever can we say that a unitary
evolving superposition has been measured
and the measure
produced a single random outcome
and
so this starts all the
area of interpretations of quantum
mechanics and i will not talk about that
i will talk about something less
theoretical
quantum gravity
and so
what really initiated this research is
uh uh schemes when he cared about
different kind of microscopic
superpositions
and superpositions of space-time
geometries in idea safety
so
uh
it's just one slide on idea safety so
don't worry
if
we have a geometry that contains a black
hole
it can be described by one state and the
absence of a black behold can be this
state
and we can also talk about
superpositions of the two
and um and what he really wondered is
whether computational complexity can
give the ultimate criterion for when two
branches of quantum state
are separated for good
and
um his conjecture was that uh detecting
coherence between two quantum state is
as hard as the relative state complexity
um
so detecting coherence is telling
for example the phase between the two
branches
or
distinguishing a superposition from a
mixture
telling if if a superposition collapsed
or not
and relative state complexity is
the
number of gates that require to map
one branch to the other
so
what his conjecture was that
if we increase
the number of gates the if the distance
the relative state complexity between
the two branches is very very large
um
then it will take a very complicated
experiment uh to tell if they are in
superposition or just
or not and this will be an effective
collapse
so we proved that his
conjecture is basically true
so here is the most simple theorem in
our paper
so given two orthogonal states alive and
dead
suppose there is a quantum circuit with
t gates that distinguishes a ls ali plus
dead and alive minus dead
then there is also a quantum circuit
with approximately t gates that swaps
alive and dead states
so what it means is that
if someone hands you a schrodinger cut
state
in order to verify that you have a
schredinger card state and not just a
mixture of
probability half a live probability of
dead
you need the computational power to
revive a dead cut to to swap and alive
in that cut
and
and assuming that you don't
we live in a world that this is
impossible
uh the death is permanent and uh it
means that in for our perspective we we
can never really observe a schrodinger
cut
or alternatively in the
wigner
friend experiment
uh if wigner can watch his friend in
superposition of
two
two states
then it means that a beginner can also
swap the
mental state of his friend
and his friend doesn't have
he's not really a free agent
[Music]
so
and when we generalize this to imperfect
distinguishing and imperfect swapping
and uh i just want to mention that there
is a previous work by akira one of
involved that
gave something similar but with less
less quantified
um
yeah so
so so really the the
the technical quantity here is the swap
complexity and that really interests me
uh the future research
um which is the complexity of of
swapping uh two uh
two states
and that that
in which we prove that it correctly
captured the hardness of current
occurrence detection
so stop complexity is not the same as
relative state complexity and we we
found an exponential separation between
the two
and also interestingly it's not even a
metric
the triangle inequality is not always
doesn't always hold
[Music]
so
as
for for summary in in quantum gravity uh
like learning wanted we we can treat
superposition over space time as
effectively decohered
uh we have two so so that we have two a
different set of operators in its base
time unless it's feasible to swap
one space time with the other
this is unconditional so
no
complexity theory assumptions were made
so no polynomial time experiment
can observe interference between a state
that is exponentially complex in a state
that
that isn't
and um
assuming and with previous result by
around the
ebay sorry around sun and suskind
if p space is not contained in the pp
slash poly
then no polynomial time experiment can
observe interference between an early
time and extremely late time cft states
and in in foundational implication
uh so our results are the formula is the
the folklore that uh interference
between branches
stop being detectable precisely when uh
irreversibility sets in
and
we sort of quantify what we give some
kind of way to quantify what is
reversibility by uh by this swap
complexity
and
interestingly uh the reversibility here
is not induced by some random
interaction with the environment like
like we're used to
um even if everything is unitary
you can get some sort of effective
irreversibility effective decoherence uh
just from a computational complexity
just from the
uh
what the observer the the the
computational power of the observer
and and this really depends up on the
power of the observer so
different observers can look at the same
system one can see a collapse and the
other can
see still a superposition
that's it
thank you
[Music]
so
why is uh distinguishing
a live plus dead from a live minus dev
the same thing as distinguishing
you know uh coherency from a mixture
so if you cannot tell
the phrase between them
then
this i guess if you try to build a
density matrix uh from this and knowing
that you cannot differentiate between
them
sort of you lose some of the diagonal
elements you just look at the mixture
it's just an operation
okay so it's just like a little lemon or
something that
those are
yeah one reduces to that okay
where does the swap gate fail to be a
metric is